voilà on se retrouve donc à oslo avec le
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
merci de nous accorder cet entretien
alors ce nobel il récompense bien sûr
l'onu mais il récompense aussi l'homme
vous même et on entend dire kofi annan
c'est le meilleur diplomates du monde
alors est-ce que vous allez quand même
un plaisir personnel
un peu un peu égoïste un peu narcissique
quand même à recevoir ce prix aussi ça
compte
c'est naturel évidemment je suis très
content mais c'est aussi un défi un défi
parce que les gens vont demander moins
de monde et beaucoup plus de moi et vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya une touche un
style une efficacité kofi annan qu'on
récompense aussi chez s'est défait des
chaises et ma façon je ne sais pas si
c'est un style kofi annan mais c'est la
mienne alors une des actualités du jour
reste l'afghanistan où la chasse à
oussama ben laden continue vous
souhaiter qu'il soit pris vivant pour
être jugé effectivement c'était les
additionne le conseil de sécurité que
les gens qui ont été accusés d'avoir
organisé les attaques du 11 septembre
doivent être jugés donc j'espère qu'un
peu les plombs biberon elle est jugée et
l'idée d'un jugement devant des
tribunaux militaires américains est ce
que c'est une des kivu qui vous gêne
ça doit nous gêne et pasquet non maman
dans une société y a
des institutions et des institutions
juridiques des règles qui doit être
appliquée à tout le monde et donc on
doit faire très attention ce n'est pas
vraiment changé des règles du jeu elles
m'ont mots venus parce qu'on en a besoin
d es
arrêtez telle ou telle personne l'aide
doit doit s'appliquer à tout le monde
non l'autre dossier brûlant c'est le
proche orient
on entend souvent dire que s'il n'y a
pas une intervention extérieure et on
pense bien sûr à celle de l'onu la
situation ne sera jamais débloqué est-ce
qu'il faut une initiative ou une
intervention de l'onu
là bas effectivement je ne crois pas que
les despatie seul arrogé la paix entre
heures donc il faut une intervention et
laisse derrière cette intervention je
crois que ça doit baigner de la
communauté de national et pour quelqu'un
qui travaille très étroitement avec
l'union européenne les américains et les
russes
donc on travaille à 4 asseyons d'être
hubert moyen des dix fait avancer la
processus la paix au moyen orient
yasser arafat est toujours un
interlocuteur incontournable
prenez moi c'est les seuls donc depuis
votre entrée en fonction c'était en
janvier 97 vous n'avez pas ménager vos
efforts de médiateur les poignées de
mains ont été nombreuses notamment à
saddam hussein c'était en 1998 et puis à
slobodan milosevic
est-ce que ses poignets mains sont
nécessaires vous vous interdisez aucune
rencontre enfin bon on peut pas tout je
les ai isoler les ignorer on est obligé
d'être était à becker pour raisonner
avec pour les pousser des faits ce qui
est nécessaire pour protéger des gens et
je suis prêt à le fait si gpse benabid
une seule personne monsieur la nano
cours de vos années de mandat qu'elle a
été l'interlocuteur le plus difficile la
négociation la plus difficile
saddam n'était pas facile l'ex-président
du congo démocratique adq chez cette
cabine a était assez difficile aussi et
avec les états unis a avec les états
unis si c'est compliqué parce que on n'a
pas affaire à une seule personne
parce que si on était obligé décrété
avec les présidents des états unis avec
les sénans avec le congrès mais les
choses semblent aller mieux avec les
etats-unis depuis le 11-septembre
finalement c'est une des leçons de ce
qui s'est passé en septembre et savait
déjà commencé à aller mieux mais c'est
qu'on a vu une accélération et je crois
qu'elle est les événements d une sorte
d'homme nous a fait comprendre qu on
partage la même vie
on ne peut pas ignoble qu'est ce qui se
passe dans un pays à un autre et je
crois que si on doit tirer une leçon de
cette expérience et les cinq et on doit
on doit on doit aider tu demandes on
doit travailler ensemble on doit
coopérer pour initier et vivre en paix
d'un segment